[Scale Swap Challenge:]
[We asked three imaging specialists to
swap scales and share their results.]
[#1: Astro to Photo]
[Clara Sousa-Silva, Quantum Astrochemist]
Clara Sousa-Silva: So what you see here is the high
resolution CCD solar spectrum. So that's
basically the rainbow of the sun in its full
detail, and this was obtained professionally,
not by me, by the current team at Harvard.
And I think about this image all the time,
I have this framed in my house you know, there's
just a complexity to all these lines and each line
corresponds to an atom or a
molecule at the edge of the sun,
and as a spectroscopist in space we're just
always counting photons. And so I thought, okay
for my new scale I'm going to look at something
that has an abundance of photons. So I was just
trying to look at the sun too but with my own
handheld spectrometer that I keep in my purse
just in case an interesting light source comes
my way. And I felt similarly to Jess that there
was an elusiveness to these images. I was trying
to capture both the sky and the spectrum of light
from the sun and you can see that all of those
millions, actually billions, of absorption lines
from the previous picture completely disappear
and it just looks like a continuous rainbow.
And I can imagine for the first people who saw the
the lines in the spectrum of the sun, apparently,
so the story goes, they thought it was dead
they thought it was a problem with their prism
and I can totally imagine that because from this
perspective the sun just seems like a continuous
source of light, no interruptions and then what
I found was it was almost impossible to get
the spectrum and the sky in focus which of course
makes sense to anyone here who does photography,
but that hadn't even crossed my mind. In my
mind this photograph would have been kind of
a beautiful, just adjust a position, and instead I
could only focus on the spectrum. So then I tried
something close to home and I saw that the light
in my hallway was old, and old lights tend to
not be, you know, LED continued spectrum and I
was not disappointed so it's just a beautiful
emission spectrum and this was such a pleasure
to actually try and capture, but the elusiveness
was so so true at this point I was trying to get
the camera aligned with the spectroscope and the
light hitting just right and I was trying to get
the echo of the spectra, the edge's spectrometer
and even though I had an abundance of
photons I didn't have any stability and so
I really struggled with this and I have a whole
new appreciation for the instruments I use and the
architecture and engineering that goes into them
because spectra is hard at every scale it seems.